well let's talk a bit more shall we
about ukraine's possible eu membership
we're joined now by philip ingram the
former british military intelligence
colonel and nato planner to give us his
analysis on the latest in ukraine so
should we start off by talking about
that bid for eu membership um here's a
map of uh you can see uh the eu there uh
ukraine all the way there over in the
east it feels almost as if the war has
pushed it to look a bit more westwards
it is it's significant from a strategic
perspective because we were hearing
rumblings from schultz of germany and
macron of france in not necessarily
supporting the military actions and what
was going on inside ukraine and
potentially suggesting solutions uh
where ukraine would have to trade some
territory that has been put to bed now
completely and therefore from a
strategic perspective vladimir putin
knows that europe is completely behind
ukraine and that will be worrying him
from an operational perspective you know
getting into the ground that will help
embolden the ukrainian military the the
ukrainian politicians and their staff
and then from a tactical perspective
it's not really going to affect things
um on the short term but it does give
that extra bit of emboldenment to the to
the troops that are fighting hard and
you don't you can't underestimate how
important it is to get that that
psychology behind what it is that
they're doing and therefore it'll help
them fight um even harder that's
interesting particularly at a time when
it feels like so many of those troops
are really having to dig in as the
battle intentions the most important
factor we talk about kit all the time we
talk about weapons they're very
important but the most important factor
when it comes to this guttural warfare
and it is guttural is the human factor
let's look at the map again shall we
because it does feel as if russia is
continuing to push
in uh certain areas uh doesn't it uh
really over in the east i mean you can
see all this kind of red uh
intensifying on the borders with russia
how is the current situation going it is
russia's main effort is in through
several donetsk they're trying to close
um this particular pocket here um
encircle the ukrainian defenders that
are in there um and try to capture the
rest of the disputed donbass region if
they manage to do that they will
probably trans sue for peace however the
secondary russian effort is to try and
stop up in the northeast around kharkiv
uh the ukrainian attacks there and their
suggestions right up to the russian
border and then we're seeing indications
of successes down in here in the in the
south west where the ukrainians are
pushing forward and the russians are
trying to defend that and of course
we've got the black sea you know there's
reports today of a russian tugboat um
that has just been um sunk around snake
island it was more than just a tugboat
it was also a resupply vessel that's
there and that was the first reported
use of harpoon anti-ship missiles that
have been supplied by the west um so
there are real effects happening on the
ground just to talk a little bit about
the kind of end goals of this and in
the way out if you like i mean we're not
talking about keeve anymore that's not
even marked on the map and if you
remember the early days of the war you
know it felt like we could be in a
situation where it would have fallen and
now it feels look you can see the
fighting really intensifying in the
south you know kind of mario paul
obviously falling and then in the uh
donbass region as well
can you see a
situation where russia tries to
purely take the dumbass or do you think
that actually no territory at all
is really up for grabs in this war well
i think russia is trying hard to take
the donbass they've said that they lost
cave they lost up around hakeev and what
they're doing in the northeast so
they've lost two major battles so far as
um admiral sir tony radkin said today
the chief of uh
the chief of defense staff and uk
military the russians have lost
strategically they're they're growing
the eu and they're growing nato and
they're bringing greater resolve
together tactically if they can get the
donbass region putin will see that as
some form of success however the resolve
we got out of the european leaders
visits yesterday saying that they didn't
see russia's ability to hold any
ukrainian territory as being key and i
think
president zielinski will have
convinced them of that that's that's the
key bit here significant that's very
significant indeed it does feel
significant thank you so much for coming
on and and telling us you know a bit of
what is really going on in ukraine all
important stories so thank you so much